the season premiere of The Bachelorette
left somebody kicked off but not Britt
or Kaitlyn meet Ryan Ryan is from Kansas
City and Ryan likes to drink and get
offensive it was all madami lon I don't
know couple halls if you're palling more
women like me words and H words Yoona
shows a sixth thing disrespect for
everybody yeah you're very Brian
approved um okay I'm sorry
Wow I didn't mean what a gentleman
he also likes to drink and get in pools
whoa he likes to get to the next level
of offensive why am I not waving you
right now
why is rapier gonna work and then when
Chris Harrison has had enough Ryan has
to get in a van you're clearly not here
for either one of these girls or first
sincere reasons yeah I really think it's
best to be too home the company Ryan was
sent home for his ridiculous behavior
and considering the show's gotten
criticism for objectifying women by
using two bachelorettes this season glad
to see them sticking up for what's right
for the ladies here by arrived
you